MAX SALTONSTALL: Welcome to
"BeyondCorp in a Bottle,"
where we explore
journeys into the world
of context-aware access
and zero trust networking.
As your modern applications
evolve and grow,
you end up with a set of
services, apps, deployments,
and resources that need to
interact with each other,
often across disparate networks.
These tend to grow
organically, and that quickly
gets messy, or
downright unmanageable.
Let's look at EatAnd.Run,
a small startup,
catering to joggers,
hikers, and power walkers
who get peckish on the go.
They've been going
quickly since launch,
and have some pretty personal
information about the clients
that they need to secure.
They knew that fully
open access wouldn't
work for their systems.
Too high risk of leaks.
Adding layers of firewall rules
quickly became unmanageable,
so they turned to
Identity Aware Proxy,
along with identity and access
management to solve this.
After they set up some
basic IAP access controls,
they wanted to go further.
The product team got excited
about new social sharing
features being
developed in the app,
and they needed to keep
these features quiet
until they were
ready for prime time.
So they pushed a new version
of the App Engine back in live.
We used IAP to restrict
it to just the engineering
team for internal testing.
To further protect the
innovations they had brewing,
the EatAnd.Run security team
made the development version
of their web app restricted to
people using up to date Chrome
OS devices with a screen
lock, so no data might
leak inadvertently through
snooping or lost laptops.
These sorts of
access policies can
be defined quickly in
Access Context Manager,
or via a YAML file.
The EatAnd.Run team realized
that a binary policy was too
simplistic for their needs, so
they decided to set up three
trust tiers--
breakfast, lunch, and supper.
These access levels are based
on the status of the employee's
operating system, screen
lock, and disk encryption,
and help IAP decide
whether or not
a given request gets
to the protected apps.
Now the EatAnd.Run team can
enjoy some peace of mind,
knowing that only the right
people on secure devices
will be able to play
with these new features.
Take a look at the
blog post linked below
to see more details on how
the team set up these access
controls and figure out if you
qualify for breakfast or lunch
at EatAnd.Run.
Thanks for watching.
Subscribe here to get more
videos on context-aware access.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]